Aaron Siegel, better known to Foundation members
as O5-1, descends into the abyss of a Deepwell
site.
He exits the elevator and peers into the optical
scanner to unlock the reinforced door.
Inside the room is Mobile Task Force Tau-5…
Samsara.
Aaron Siegel refers to these immortal cyborg
clones, created from the flesh of a dead god,
as his Red Right Hand.
“Your mission is to eliminate the traitor
O5-4, and to find the insurgents who have
been killing the members of the Overseer Council.”
The cyborgs stand at attention.
“Now!”
Aaron Siegel screams.
The soldiers of the Red Right Hand march out
the door to start their mission.
Aaron Siegel pauses for a moment and then
slams his fist against the wall in frustration.
He has lost nine Overseers to Calvin Lucien
and his Kill Squad team.
They have been somehow overcoming the odds
each time, and eliminating each Overseer they
track down.
It wasn’t supposed to end this way.
Aaron Siegel vows to kill them all.
Calvin Lucien, meanwhile, sits on a private
jet with Adam and Olivia.
He had just hung up the phone after a conversation
with O5-4.
The Overseer known as the Ambassador wants
to surrender to the Insurgency.
There’s a good chance this is a trap, but
Calvin has decided to meet with the Ambassador
all the same.
Calvin drops off Adam and Olivia at an Insurgency
base.
They still haven’t fully recovered from
the previous mission with O5-5, known as the
Blackbird.
Before leaving though, Calvin meets with an
Insurgency agent named Sylvester Sloan, who
is going to join him as support.
Calvin says goodbye to Adam and Olivia, then
leaves with Sloan to meet The Ambassador in
South Africa.
After landing at Johannesburg airport, Calvin
and Sloan disembark and are led to a conference
room where the Ambassador sits waiting for
them.
Calvin and Sloan sit across from O5-4 to discuss
his surrender.
“The Council is in shambles,” says The
Ambassador, “everything is falling apart.
I want to offer my services and information
to the Insurgency in exchange for protection
from O5-1.
He has lost his mind.”
Calvin agrees to the terms and prepares for
extraction.
But as they get up from the table gunshots
can be heard from down the hall.
The Ambassador’s eyes open wide in terror.
“It’s too late,” he whispers.
Calvin and Sloan grab the Ambassador, who
is frozen in fear, and exit the conference
room.
They make their way toward their plane, but
the gun shots are getting closer.
Calvin looks over his shoulder to see Samsara
pursuing them through the terminal.
Calvin shoves the Ambassador behind a table
as bullets whiz overhead.
Calvin and Sloan return fire, but their volly
doesn’t seem to slow down the assassins.
Calvin and Sloan pull the Ambassador to his
feet and they burst through an emergency exit
onto the sun baked tarmac where they make
a mad dash for the plane.
From behind them a bullet rips through the
chest of Sloan.
The Red Right Hand has caught up, but Calvin
continues to drag the Ambassador towards the
plane.
They are almost there.
Suddenly, a metallic child’s voice blares
through the airport’s external speakers.
The child’s voice says, “I want Calvin
Lucien alive.
I have business to settle with him.”
The Red Right Hand soldiers tackle Calvin
and the Ambassador to the ground when they
are just feet away from the plane.
“Kill the traitor,” the child’s voice
says, and Calvin can only watch helplessly
as the Ambassador is violently murdered.
One of the agents turns towards Calvin and
slams his fist into Calvin's face causing
him to black out.
Calvin awakens in a dark room.
He is unsure how much time has passed.
The only light in the room comes from a screen
on the wall.
In the middle of the screen is a rotating,
red, SCP Foundation seal.
A voice from a speaker speaks.
“Hello Calvin Lucien, my name is The Kid.
I am the Third Overseer.
You have killed all of my friends... and now
I will kill all of yours.”
The door to the room opens.
Calvin leans through the doorway.
There is a long, dimly lit, hallway.
The Kid orders him to proceed, so that they
can meet face to face.
As Calvin walks, the Kid’s voice echoes
down the hallway.
“There once was another O5-3.
He built incredible machines, even one that
could see into the future.
But unfortunately for him, he did not have
the passion required to be an Overseer.
That was when I was… born.
I was chosen by the other Overseers to have
my spinal cord severed in a way that gave
me the ability of the All-Seeing Eye.
I now watch everything, all of the time.
I have perfect reasoning, perfect awareness,
and perfect understanding.”
Calvin gets to the end of the corridor, which
opens up into a large chamber.
Tied up in the middle of the room are Olivia
and Adam.
Calvin runs to his friends and crouches down
next to them.
A mechanical suit stands on a platform looking
down at Calvin, Olivia, and Adam.
Calvin realizes the Kid must be contained
inside.
“I now sentence you all to death,” the
mechanical suit says as the Red Right hand
steps out of the shadows and slowly walks
towards the remaining members of the Killsquad.
Suddenly, there is a flash of light and The
Black Queen appears.
“Stop!
What are you doing?” shrieks the Kid.
The Black Queen hands Calvin the interdimensional
rod and reel he used to defeat the Blackbird.
Calvin casts the rod.
From out of the tear in space comes a massive,
multi-armed creature, known as Malidramagiuan.
The Red Right Hand engages the monster trying
to force it back into its dimension.
But the monster is too powerful.
It grabs the cyborg clones and pulls them
through the tear in reality.
As Samsara battles the Malidramagiuan, Calvin
frees Olivia and Adam.
They make a run for the door, but as they
flee, one of the walls opens up to reveal
a turret.
The gun fires and a bullet hits Olivia directly
in the head, killing her instantly.
“No!” yells Calvin.
But before Calvin can push Adam out of the
way, a second bullet from the turret lodges
itself in Adam’s back.
Calvin and Adam slide across the floor.
The Kid in his mechanical suit jumps down
from the platform above.
“I am going to kill you now Calvin Lucien,”
he says in his mechanical voice.
There is another flash of light.
Calvin watches in front of him as the Spear
of the Non-Believer manifests itself before
his eyes.
Calvin grabs the spear and shoves it into
The Kid’s machine body.
It easily penetrates the armor and pins him
to the wall.
Calvin walks up to the exoskeleton and tears
off the outer plating, revealing a tank full
of fluid, within which floats a malformed
human fetus.
As Calvin finally looks upon the Kid’s true
form, he hears the sound of mocking mechanical
laughter.
Calvin breaks the glass and crushes The Kid
with his bare hands.
As Calvin turns from the now silent robotic
body of The Kid, the room begins to shake,
debris raining down from above.
Calvin helps Adam up and puts Olivia’s lifeless
body across his shoulders.
What remains of the Killsquad makes their
way out of The Kid’s lair.
Outside of the Foundation site where they
were being held, Calvin helps Adam to lie
down on the ground before gently setting Olivia’s
body next to him.
Adam grimaces as blood pours out of the wound
in his back.
Calvin reaches into his pocket and pulls out
the vial of water from the Fountain of Youth.
There are only a couple drops left, which
he pours into Adam’s mouth.
Adam looks up at Calvin, tears filling his
eyes, he whispers “I love you” before
he passes out from the pain.
The wound in his back begins to heal instantly
and Calvin calls an Insurgency evac team to
come pick up Adam.
With Adam safe, Calvin picks up Olivia and
walks alone towards a truck in the lot outside
of the Foundation site.
He needs to finish this once and for all.
He will kill the last two Overseers, or he
will die trying.
O5-1, Aaron Siegel arrives at where the Tigris
and Euphrates rivers meet.
The Garden of Eden.
He is in a frenzy due to the assassinations
of all the other Overseers besides himself
and The Nazarene and nothing will stop him.
As he approaches the gate to the Garden of
Eden though, he is stopped by the Guardian
of the Garden, a massive, powerful anomalous
entity with a flaming sword.
But Aaron Siegel has no time, or patience,
for anything to get in his way.
Even something as powerful as the Gate Guardian.
The Guardian swings his burning sword at Adam
who rolls out of the way and, in a flash,
takes out a Scranton Reality Anchor.
He slams the anchor into the ground which
causes the world to shimmer and ripple around
him.
He watches as the flames from the Gate Guardian’s
sword seem to absorb back into its body, before
it shrinks down, looking to fold in on itself
until all that is left is a charred skeleton.
With the Guardian defeated, Aaron sprints
into the Garden.
He searches the garden for O5-2, but can’t
find her anywhere.
He finally comes to the Tree of Life, and
that’s where he finds her.
Laying at the base of the tree in a pool of
blood is The Nazarene, she has taken her own
life.
This is her anomalous power though.
She has died many times before yet Death always
spared her and brought her back.
But somehow, he knows this time is final.
Aaron drops to his knees and screams in frustration.
For all the power Aaron Siegel possesses,
there’s nothing he can do now.
He sits next to The Nazarene’s body for
hours, hoping that she might wake up, or that
he will to find that this was all a dream.
After sitting next to her cold body for some
time, he notices something in her snowy white
hand.
It’s a note.
In it The Nazarene explains that she was the
one who gave the vials from the Fountain to
Calvin Lucien, and that she is the one who
made the spear appear before him that he used
to kill The Kid.
She explained that while she died many times
and Death always brought her back, each time
she felt less and less like herself, less
and less like Dr. Sophia Light.
She hoped that maybe if things ended up like
this, it would give Aaron the chance to walk
away and live the life that they might have
been able to have together, but she knows
deep down that Aaron’s fate is to meet Calvin
and finish things once and for all.
Aaron Siegl screams in rage, clutching the
note in his hand.
He tries to summon Death, but no one comes.
Aaron Siegel is alone.
He stands up and walks deeper into the Garden.
He walks until he reaches a spot where even
God’s light does not reach.
In this desolate land is an impact crater
where Lucifer, Star of the Morning, had fallen.
In the middle of the crater lies Lucifer’s
sword.
Aaron Siegel descends into the hole and picks
up the sword.
He turns and exits the Garden of Eden.
Aaron Siegel has only one mission in life
now… to kill Calvin Lucien.
Calvin reads the final entry of the journal.
In it the author warns that although he hopes
the information contained within the journal
is helpful, he hopes the reader does not try
to use it.
The words written on the final page are: “this
information will only lead you to a devastating
end.”
Calvin closes the journal and looks up at
the structure in front of him.
He has made it to Site-01.
He had left Olivia’s body in a cave nearby,
promising to her that he would make this right.
He now walks up to the massive doors and places
his hand on the knotted wood.
The doors slowly creek open.
Calvin pauses for a moment and looks behind
him at the setting sun, he enters Site-01,
where he knows O5-1 is.
Where Aaron Siegel waits.
Inside the main hall Calvin sees a giant doorway
in the shape of the SCP Foundation seal, with
artistic depictions of certain SCPs that he
instinctively knows are special in some way.
Standing next to the doorway is a 2 meter
tall man in what looks to be a futuristic
suit.
Calvin approaches and asks who this giant
man is, he responds that his name is Purpose,
the Red Right Hand.
He is the guardian of O5-1 and none shall
enter the sanctum until he returns.
“He isn’t here?” asks Calvin.
“No” Purpose responds, “he is.”
And with that he steps aside and lets Calvin
pass through the doorway.
The doorway leads into a large room where
screens on the wall flash to life, depicting
moments from Calvin’s journey, documenting
his entire quest.
Had he been in control at all?
Or was this all a setup to lead him to this
moment?
As he walks forward he finally sees him.
Sitting at a table in the middle of the room,
is Aaron Siegel.
“You are O5-1?”
Calvin asks.
“Aaron” the man responds.
“My name is Aaron.”
Calvin asks about the location of the second
Overseer, the Nazarene, but O5-1 doesn’t
respond.
Without needing any more information, Calvin
pulls out his sidearm and in a flash fires
off five shots.
The bullets stopped in the air, inches away
from Aaron, before dissolving in a flash of
light.
Calvin should have known it wouldn’t be
this easy.
“Stand up, Aaron Siegel” Calvin calls
out as he holsters his gun.
“Let’s finish it.”
Calvin pulled the spear of the non-believer
from his back but Aaron’s only response
was to laugh.
“You don’t even know why you’re here”
Aaron said.
Calvin calls back “I’m here to kill you,
because when I do, I kill the Foundation.
Because when you’re gone the universe can
finally heal.”
“You’re like me, Calvin Lucien.
We are both men driven by our own convictions,
regardless of the outcome.
It would seem fate has brought us together.
Now, either your convictions will be broken,
or you will die,” says Aaron Siegel.
He then draws Lucifer’s flaming sword and
lunges towards
As the two men clash with one another, their
supernatural weapons begin to destroy the
room around them.
Furniture is shattered, video screens are
obliterated, and fire spreads across the walls.
Aaron catches Calvin off balance and swings
the flaming sword across Calvin’s stomach.
Calvin slides back from the impact, hunching
over from the pain in his midsection.
He brings his head up to see Aaron Sigel running
towards him with the flaming sword high in
the air.
Calvin brings up the spear; from his knees
he leans back and launches it towards Aaron
Siegel.
The spear enters the final Overseer’s chest;
the force from the throw pinning him against
the wall.
Aaron Siegel drops Lucifer’s sword.
It shatters as it hits the ground.
He clutches the shaft of the spear protruding
from his sternum with both hands.
O5-1 looks at Calvin unbelievingly.
“You have no idea what you’ve done.
It was never about the Overseers,” Aaron
Siegel says, spitting out blood with every
word.
“It was something deeper - something worse.”
Calvin walks slowly towards Aaron Siegel.
He stops just in front of his final enemy.
“This is the way it ends,” Calvin says.
Aaron Siegel manages to whisper one final
word “Sophia…” before his body finally
goes limp.
Calvin turns to see Purpose standing behind
him.
“He’s dead” Calvin says, half to Purpose
and half to himself “I killed him.”
After a moment he asks Purpose what he really
wants to know.
“There’s a room in this facility where
someone could unmake the Foundation, right?
Take me there.”
Without any hesitation, Purpose leads Calvin
back to the room with depictions of important
SCPs.
There, Purpose opens the door to an elevator
but stops Calvin before he can get inside.
“I’m duty bound to tell you” Purpose
says, “that once you step inside this elevator,
there is no going back.
There is only one decision to be made and
it is not one that can be unmade.”
“I know,” Calvin responds.
“It’s time” before stepping inside.
The elevator doors open to reveal a room filled
with bookcases and a huge window offering
a beautiful view of the sun setting behind
the mountains.
On the wall are more monitors depicting the
ways he had killed all of the Overseers, and
in the middle of the room is a large desk
with a computer.
Calvin sits down at the desk and the computer
comes to life.
The computer prompts him to scan his fingerprint,
which it accepts.
He’s logged in.
The computer screen displays numerous locations
around the planet, and he quickly recognizes
that they are all SCP Foundation sites.
Then he sees the single option the computer
is giving him.
“Terminate”
Calvin reaches out with his finger, this is
it, once he presses this button, the SCP Foundation
will be no more.
His finger is millimeters from the button
when -
The phone rings.
Calvin hadn’t even noticed that there was
a phone on the desk Calvin stares at it for
a moment then picks it up.
“Hello?” he says.
The voice on the other line responds.
“Hello Calvin Lucien, my name is The Administrator.
I have been following your work for some time
now, and I must say, I am impressed.
I have just been informed that you have completed
your mission, congratulations are in order.”
“What the hell are you talking about?”
Calvin asks.
“Please listen,” says the voice on the
other line.
“The man you just killed was once in the
same exact position you are in now.
Granted, it was a very long time ago, but
Aaron Siegel originally was trying to destroy
the Foundation; that was until I convinced
him otherwise.
And now, like Aaron Siegel, you will become
the new head of the Foundation.”
“Like hell I will!” yells Calvin.
“I could hang up, walk away right now, and
be done with all of this!”
“You could,” continues the Administrator,
“But if no one is in charge of the SCP Foundation,
millions of people will die, if not billions,
and then nobody would be there to manage what
comes after.”
There is silence from Calvin.
“That’s what I thought,” says the Administrator.
“I look forward to working with you Calvin
Lucien… or should I say O5-1.”
The line goes dead.